[Musique]
bonsoir jeudi 26 novembre bienvenue dans
le journal de tv 78 voici les titres de
cette édition la disparition de pierre
celle un courrier à mercredi à 83 ans il
a été le maire communiste de la verrière
pendant 29 ans entre 1983 et 2012
vice-présidente saint quentin en
yvelines
il y a huit ans l'ancien élu avait
démissionné du conseil municipal fatigué
par des soucis cardiaques
les premières réactions à suivre c'est
la convention d'affaires pour les
acteurs économiques de saint quentin en
yvelines le sky business days se
dérouler aujourd'hui crise sanitaire
oblige les événements à l'accoutumée au
vélodrome nationale s'est tenue cette
année
100% en ligne le bilan dans quelques
instants et puis rappelez vous c'était
fin février 2010 9 900 mètres cubes
d'hydrocarbures se déversait dans des
champs à authouillet conséquences de la
rupture du pipeline d'ile-de-france de
total le chantier de dépollution qui a
débuté à la suite de l'incident s'est
achevée il ya peu mais avant de
développer ses titres deux jours après
l'allocution d'emmanuel macron le
premier ministre jean castex et des
ministres du gouvernement a porté ce
matin des précisions sur la levée
progressive du confinement le détail
assure notamment plusieurs mesures des
mesures qui débuteront dès samedi avec
concernant le protocole sanitaire
renforcée pour les commerces la jauge
qui est porté à 8 mètres carrés par
client elle s'applique à toute la
surface de vente et ne prend pas en
compte les employés les commerces de
plus que 2 400 m² devons prévoir une
personne un système de comptage à noter
aussi qu ils pourront ouvrir jusqu'à 21h
et des dérogations seront possibles pour
une ouverture dominicale et les auto
écoles pourront dès ce 28 novembre
reprendre les cours en vue des épreuves
du permis de conduire les enseignements
concernant le code est de la route
devront être maintenus à distance les
visites immobilière pourront également
reprendre le samedi 28 novembre
et dès samedi prochain les activités
sportives individuelles seront à nouveau
autorisée autorisé le sport en lieu clos
et les sports collectifs de contacts
restent eux interdit pour l'instant les
activités extrascolaires intérieur
reprendront elles le 15 décembre
enfin en ce qui concerne le monde de la
culture les commerces culturels et les
bio
tech qui rouvriront dès ce week-end pour
les musées les cinémas et les salles de
théâtre ce sera le 15 décembre prochain
il en sera de même pour les activités
artistiques dispensés dans les
conservatoires et des écoles de musique
seul le chant n'est pas encore autorisé
avec moi en visio alexandre arrosé de si
bons soirs maire de la commune de
voisins-le-bretonneux vice-présidente de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en charge du
développement économique et de l'actrice
l'attractivité du territoire ce jeudi
l'agglomération organisé est la
cinquième édition du sky business day
c'est la convention d'affaires de saint
quentin en yvelines et une crise
sanitaire oblige à obliger la crise
sanitaire a organisé l'événement qui est
à l'accoutumée au vélodrome cette
fois-ci 100% en ligne au travers d'un
système de visioconférence déjà une
première question quel premier bilan
faites vous de cette journée
alors le premier bilan est plutôt
encourageant c'est vrai que j'avais
souhaité que les équipes de saint
quentin travail très tôt sur un concept
100% en ligne puisque on savait que sans
doute on pourrait pas se rencontrer et
les entreprises elles sont au rendez
vous puisque à ce nous avons eu 400
entreprises qui se sont inscrits dont si
on compare à 2019 il y en avait six ans
sur cinq cents 500 participants c'est à
dire que les entreprises peuvent envoyer
plusieurs participants donc c'était 900
2019 avec quand même plus de 1000
rendez-vous qui on avait pu être retenus
ont contre 2000 en 2019 vous voyez on
voit on voit la différence mais en tout
cas ça c'est plutôt très bien déroulé
différents certes mais avec donc ce
contexte de la crise sanitaire qui a
poussé une organisation sans qu'on
s'enligne est-ce que ça ça démontre
quand même que malgré cette crise
sanitaire cette crise économique
l'activité économique sur le territoire
reste dynamique
luis a démontré qu'il ya toujours de
l'appétence pour faire des affaires et
les entreprises ont vraiment besoin de
ce type de rendez vous il ya eu aussi
des animations diverses et des
webinaires des tables rondes de toute la
journée avec en moyenne de 365
participation à ces diverses animations
donc il ya eu le côté prise de rendez
vous qui a bien fonctionné et puis les
animations aussi bon je crois qu'on peut
dire que c'était vraiment une formule
qui était bien adapté à ce contexte avec
des des retours très positifs des
entreprises même si ils ont quand même
souligner qu' il ya besoin vraiment en
ce moment de contact humain ce qui est
pas évident quand on fait pourtant le
fait en ligne avec des difficultés on
imagine à mettre vite les choses en
place pour organiser cette formule du
sky business day dans une formule un peu
spéciale 1 cette année
voilà et d'ailleurs je profite pour vous
remercier déjà puisque vous avez
participé à cette mise en place dès ce
matin avec l'ouverture de cette journée
les équipes de développement économique
de la maison de l'entreprise de saint
quentin en yvelines vraiment ont tout
fait pour ça fonctionne bien je les en
remercie vraiment vivement et puis je
voudrais aussi remercier les partenaires
parce que ils ont aussi répondu présents
tels que mercedes la société générale a
cessé il a french tech paris saclay
convergence del pascal initiative qui
voit là pour tous ses partenaires ont
fait que cette cette belle cette journée
est vraiment été une réussite
sortons de ce sky business day pour
parler d'un autre sujet avec sandra
rosetti on a appris aujourd'hui la
disparition de pierre celle un cours à
83 ans maire communiste de la derrière
pendant 29 ans entre 1983 et 2012 vous
l'avez côtoyé notamment sein de
l'agglomération il a été vice-président
de cette agglomération quel est votre
réactions et quel est le souvenir que
vous avez envie de garder de lui alors
je vais me la prendre c'est un peu un
choc je suis très triste parce que quand
il était vice président en charge de la
culture à 50 ans j'avais noué des liens
vraiment très sympathique avec lui parce
que c'était un homme très cultivé avec
beaucoup d'humour et voilà j'avais grand
plaisir à travailler avec lui même si
nos idées politiques n'étaient n'était
pas du tout les mêmes évidemment mais
pour moi c'est un grand homme un
humaniste et je garderai un très très
beau souvenir de lui évidemment là je
suis très triste
merci pour cette première réaction
alexandra rosetti je le rappelle maire
de la commune de voisins-le-bretonneux
également vice président de saint
quentin en yvelines en charge du
développement économique et de
l'attractivité du territoire j'ajoute
que vous êtes est également conseillère
départementale des yvelines
merci à vous et vous l'entendiez donc si
vous nous rejoignez peut-être maintenant
sur tv 78 nous avons appris aujourd'hui
la disparition de pierre c'est lincourt
figure historique de la verrière ancien
maire communiste de la ville qui est
décédé hier mercredi à l'âge de 83 ans
il est à la tête de la commune pendant
29 ans entre 1983 et 2000 douze
militants communistes dès sa jeunesse
celui qui était instituteur est entré au
conseil municipal de la verrière en 1977
avant d'en devenir le maire en 1983 puis
il a été réélu à quatre reprises pierre
sellin cour a également été le
vice-président de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en charge de
la culture
dans un message sur son compte twitter
la mairie de la verrière qui était un
bastion communiste rappelons le pendant
plus de 40 ans qui a basculé à droite
lors des dernières élections municipales
elle a témoigné la mairie de la verrière
de sa grande tristesse après cette
disparition
elle indique la municipalité qu'un
hommage lui sera rendu bientôt à pierre
sellin cours
c'est en raison d'une santé fragile un
des soucis cardiaques en l'occurrence
que pierre stehlin cour avait passé la
main il y a huit en démissionnant de son
fauteuil de maire en 2012 à deux ans de
la fin de son cinquième mandat
un arrachage son premier adjoint de
l'époque lui avait succédé avant d'être
réélu en 2014 et de lui même démissionné
en 2016 pour raisons de santé
alain ajaj qui à bout
appris auprès de pierre sellin course se
souvient d'un homme qui a énormément
donné pour sa ville écouter entendre
christophe parce que pierre a beaucoup
marqué la ville et a beaucoup marqué
aussi ma propre existence enfin je
serais vraiment pas l'homme que je suis
aujourd'hui si je n'avais pas rencontré
un jour de 80 voilà c'était quelqu'un de
très cultivé
profondément attaché à samedi
profondément attaché à des valeurs que
nous partagions perdre une grande page
qui se tourne
la verrière avec son départ en tant que
maire de la verrière pierre celle un
cours à mener plusieurs chantiers
notamment les constructions de l'hôtel
de ville et de la médiathèque
aimé-césaire lui cet amoureux de la
culture dont il était le vice-président
également au sein de l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines il a travaillé
est notamment pendant 16 ans sous la
présidence socialiste de robert
cadalbert entre 1998 et 2000 14 malgré
des convictions politiques différentes
pierres c'est l'un court était un homme
d'ouverture
au niveau des projets écouter robert
cadalbert beaucoup de tristesse parce
que pierce et d'un cours au delà des
problèmes du parti communiste de la
ville nouvelle qui étaient contre l'avis
noël c'est d'abord une personne très
intéressante sur le plan l'humanité et
surtout sur le plan culturel
c'était attrayante intellectuelle du
parti communiste et surtout moi je
retiens surtout la tristesse de voir
voilà un homme de culture qui est
innocent qui vont pour moi c'est toute
une partie de l'histoire de 50 animaux
qui sont la majorité ex majorité de
gauche à l'agglomération le l'ancien
maire de la verrière a également
travaillé au côté de guy malandain
également ancien vice-président ancien
maire de trappes jusqu'en mars dernier
qui est toujours actuellement conseiller
municipal et conseiller communautaire et
qui malandain avait rencontré pierre
celle en cours pour la première fois en
voici sa réaction après l'annoncé de son
décès la peine toujours d'apprendre le
décès d'un ami voilà et avec le souvenir
de d'un élu qui dont dans ses options
politiques
a toujours été comment dire cet actif
pour tenter le souci à la fois de la
communauté à la fois de cinq obus de la
verrière de d'un passionné par deux
éléments
le premier élément c'est c'est lui la
personnalité des gens human quoi
l'humanisme il le deuxième élément c'est
autre réaction à vous proposer celle de
jean michel fourgous l'actuel président
à l'est républicain de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines maire
d'elancourt et salut malgré le combat
politique qui les a opposé son
engagement il salue pierre sellin cours
il salue son engagement sincère pour la
commune et pour le territoire de
l'agglomération pierre celle un cours
qui s'amusait d'ailleurs de ses nombreux
duels politique au cours de sa carrière
écouter d'ailleurs cet extrait on
l'avait enregistrée en 2012 au moment il
avait annoncé sa démission pire celle
d'un cours de son fauteuil de maire
c'était une interview collectés à
l'époque par catherine mulato écoutez je
suis maire depuis 30 ans donc j'en ai
emmenés à l'année les gens et dans des
élus et des personnels communaux dégâts
j'en ai usé un certain nombre
et puis une réaction de benoît - pour
terminer ancien ministre ancien député
des yvelines et ancien conseiller
municipal de trappes le fondateur de
génération fait part de sa tristesse sur
twitter pour cet emblématique maire
communiste la gauche perd un militant
humaniste affirme-t-il voilà ce qu'on
pouvait vous dire aujourd'hui au
lendemain de cette disparition celle de
pierre c'est lincourt ancien maire de la
verrière qui est décédé hier mercredi à
l'âge de 83 ans
[Musique]
rappelez vous c'était fin février 2010 9
900 m 2 cubes de pétrole 900 mètres
cubes de pétrole ont été déversés dans
des champs et des ruisseaux à
authouillet après la rupture du
'pipeline' ile-de-france de total après
quinze mois de travaux le groupe
pétrolier a finalement très terminée
mais je vais y arriver il a finalement
terminé le groupe pétrolier à ses
différentes interventions le chantier a
été levée avec un retour à la normale
pour les habitants de la zone
elle le point sur ce dossier avec
nicolas landry ils ont levé le chantier
le 28 octobre dernier après 15 mois
d'activité le groupe total a terminé ses
interventions sur la commune de touiller
un retour à la normale pour la vie
locale
nous avons toujours eu des contacts avec
total qui étaient de bons contacts m'ont
parfois je n'étais pas très satisfait de
certaines choses qui était normale mais
nous en avons toujours discuter le
dossier est clôturée mais le groupe
pétrolier a l'obligation de poursuivre
la surveillance de la zone et de son
infrastructure sous l'oeil attentif des
services de l'état on est dans
l'application ici d'une principe
pollueur payeur que l'on appelle la
responsabilité environnementale et fait
d'ailleurs une première en france
l'objectif pour nous étant d'éviter tout
impact sur l'environnement et tout
l'impact est bien évidemment sanitaire
bonvin inscrire dans les plans
d'urbanisme l'existence de cette
pollution
ça va durer sur du très très long terme
va permettre de garder en mémoire
l'existence de cet accident
pour rappel le 24 février 2019 une
rupture du pipeline a provoqué une fuite
de pétrole dans un champ et les cours
d'eau alentour
après avoir nettoyé les 900 mètres cubes
d'écoulement de pétrole brut
le pipeline a été réparé les terres
polluées ont été enlevées et remplacées
pour remettre le champ en l'état le
'pipeline' une infrastructure en
fonctionnement depuis 1968
c'est pas qu'il a trop de dégradations
c'est que l'investissement nécessaire
par rapport à
à son état actuel et à par rapport à ce
que les raccords 12 ans disent il faut
le mettre en perspective d'autres choses
est ce que on investirait les centaines
de millions d'euros dans ce pipe line
alors que total a une ambition zéro
carbone très très forte
le groupe total a annoncé le 24
septembre dernier la transformation de
la raffinerie de grandpuits en une
plateforme 0 pétrole ce qui deux fêtes
entraînerait la fin de l'utilisation du
pipeline d'ile-de-france et pour
continuer à parler de ce sujet deux
invités qui sont avec moi en
visioconférence il vient nous rejoindre
philippe heurtevent bonsoir est ce que
vous nous entendez si vous êtes le
président de l'association sauvons les
yvelines qui a suivi l effet après cette
rupture de pipeline à authouillet membre
également de du collectif france nature
environnement yvelines
deux des sept associations en fait un
france nature environnement et sauvons
les yvelines qui ont déposé il ya
quasiment un an
une plainte contre x avec constitution
de partie civile pour pollution des eaux
il a également avec nous marc pittie
ferrandi bonsoir bonsoir avocat au
barreau de paris spécialiste du droit
public et du droit de l'environnement et
vous défendez dans cette affaire du coup
elle est cette association
philippe heurtevent les total dit de son
côté dans le sujet que l'on vient de
voir que le dossier est clos et ce que
vous êtes du même avis aujourd'hui bien
évidemment que non on ne bat on peut pas
dire que le sujet écrit ou d'ailleurs
la preuve c'est que le représentant de
la préfecture dit exactement il faut il
ya une contradiction dans le fait qu'on
nous dit que c'est que le dossier est
clos et le représentant du préfet qui
dit il faut inscrire l'un pollution dans
les pays du parce que c'est un travail
de longue haleine est évident que
dossier n'est pas clos et lui un je
précise que c'est le plan local
d'urbanisme la sptr agricole a été
traitée on l'a vu dans ce sujet avec la
remise en état des terrains qui ont été
inondées par le par le pétrole
vous jugez vous de votre côté que
l'aspect faune et flore a été pour le
moment négliger c'est ce que vous
regrettez
et bien il y avait un arrêté du préfet a
également mis en application
pour l'instant le seul arrêté et mis en
application c'est la restauration des
terres agricoles et ça sur ce côté là on
peut pas dire que ça a été fait
extérieurement on ne regarde
l'herbe est verte dès la nature la
nature lll et elle est encore polluées
l'info de la flore on a compris que
c'est une procédure qui est encore en
cours avec cette plainte contre x pour
pollution des eaux constitution aussi de
deux parties civiles on en avait parlé
vous étiez venu sur ce plateau avec m
pythie ferrandi notamment c'était en
janvier dernier expliquez-nous déjà la
particularité de cette constitution de
partie civile m piti ferrandi ça permet
de faire nommer un juge d'instruction
c'est ça c'est ça ça permet de faire
nommer un juge d'instruction
généralement ça en quelques mois là on
attend encore la nomination d'un juge
d'instruction où d'un seulement de
recevoir ou 10 mois
une ordonnance de consignation c'est une
profession préalable à la désignation
d'un juge d'instruction ce qui arrive
aussi généralement sous quelques mois et
donc les associations vont consigner les
sommes qui sont exigés et enfin on va
pouvoir avoir la désignation d'un juge
d'instruction
ce afin de mettre en évidence dans ce
dossier les imprudences des négligences
qui ont pu être commises et aboutir à ce
que la catastrophe 2014 se répète en
2019 en deux fois pied puisque si à peu
près deux fois le volume de mètres cubes
de pétrole brut qui s'étaient déversés
en 2014 qui se sont déversés en 2019 de
nouveau ça et aussi mettre en évidence
l'intégralité des dégâts causés à
l'environnement en vue d'obtenir leur
réparation instant comme l'a souligné à
juste titre philippe fortement leur
réparation n'est pas intervenue et on
précise aussi vous l'aviez préciser
quand vous étiez venu sur ce plateau en
janvier la démarche nécessaire de cette
constitution de partie civile a été
rendue nécessaire suite à cette plainte
contre x puisque cette plainte contre x
il n'y a pas eu de suites de la part de
la procureure de la république c'est
pour ça qu'il ya eu constitution de
partie civile il ya une enquête
effectivement qui a été ouverte mais
dans le cas de l'enquète les
associations n'ont pas constaté qu'ils
aient d'actes réellement qui prennent la
mesure finalement de l'ampleur de la
catastrophe
parallèlement et c'est important de
souligner les associations aussi mis en
oeuvre une procédure administrative
celle qui est signalée par le préfet
comme la première alors lui dit c'est la
première c'est sûrement effectivement
une des premières applications du
principe pollueur payeur par la mise en
oeuvre du régime de la loi de 2008 sur
la responsabilité environnementale qui
est donc un régime dérogatoire qui
permet d'obtenir sans aller devant un
juge
l'arrêt parade et d'imposer à un
exploitant un pollueur des mesures de
réparation environnemental ce qu'a fait
le préfet à la demande des associations
à l'été 2010 9 par un premier arrêté de
réparation qui était limité aux terres
agricoles au droit du point de fuite
donc uniquement les terres qu'ils
étaient immédiatement impacté et on
attend encore un second arrêté un
troisième arrêté après inventaire des
l'ampleur des dégâts qui me pu être
causés aux autres milieux dont notamment
le mit en pratique les batraciens ont
été particulièrement impacté à résister
en pleine période de reproduction au
monde cette petite marée noire il ya
aussi d'autres espèces notamment des
espèces protégées dont des libellules au
titre de l'annexé 2 de la directive
habitats au niveau européen qui ont été
nécessairement impacté par les dégâts
monstrueux cause l environnement par la
suite et ça pour l'instant ça n'est pas
traité ça n'est pas pris en compte
le préfet reconnaît l'ampleur de la
pollution puisqu'il dit que ça va durer
très très longtemps
il faut l'inscrire dans les pme et pour
autant il n'ya pas aucune obligation
pour total pour l'instant de réparer ces
dégâts et le clae chiant pour les dégâts
qu'ils ne peuvent pas être réparé les
compenser par des mesures qui seraient
de nature à rétablir
finalement la balance écologique que
total a déséquilibré
une dernière question mark hurd philippe
fortement pardon s'adresse à vous vous
dénoncez aussi en janvier que vous
n'aviez pas eu accès au dossier
vous nous confirmer que c'est toujours
pas qu'à vous n'avez pas pu consulter
les dossiers alors ça c'est vraiment le
point le plus regrettable surtout que au
final on constate que l'accent des
associations qui était une action
constructive responsable en recherche de
partenariats à la fois avec la
préfecture les services de l'état et
gagnent mois avec les services de total
que l'on a réussi partiellement avec
total c'est vrai mais c'est regrettable
parce que nous avons été écartés est
vaste et j'ai même dit employer le mot
traité dans le mépris et ça c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas acceptable
de la part de l'état notamment dans
cette volonté qu'a aujourd'hui l'état de
se préoccuper des problèmes
environnementaux et de faire de mettre
en oeuvre une politique écologique le
fait d'écarter les associations c'est
quelque chose qui n'était pas acceptable
et nous sommes toujours aujourd'hui dans
la même situation et c'est pour là c'est
pour ça que nous sommes contraints d'en
passer par la justice pour avoir accès
au dossier et pouvoir mener à bien ce à
pois nos associations ont pour objet
c'est à dire la défense la protection
environnement dans avoir parlé sur ce
journal dans ce journal philippe
vertement président de l'association
sauvons les yvelines et marc pittie
ferrandi merci aussi d'appel d'avoir été
avec nos avocats au barreau de paris et
spécialiste du droit public et du droit
de l'environnement et donc avocats de
ces sept associations à qui a lancé
cette action en justice
[Musique]
dans l'actualité également l' enquête se
poursuit plus d'un mois après
l'assassinât de samuel pâti à conflans
sainte honorine le professeur
d'histoire-géographie avait été décapité
le 16 octobre dernier pour avoir montré
en classe des caricatures on apprend que
quatre nouveaux collégiens du bois donne
là où enseigne et samuel pâtit ont été
mises en examen dans la sphère dont
trois âgés de 13 et 14 ans pour
complicité d'assassinats terroristes ils
sont soupçonnés d'avoir désigné la
victime aux terroristes la quatrième
personne mise en examen pour
dénonciation calomnieuse n'est autre que
la fille du parent d'élève à l'origine
de la campagne médiatique contre le
professeur es deux autres collégiens
pour rappel avait été déjà mise en
examen pour complicité d'assassinats
terroristes
l'ancien préfet des yvelines serge
morvan devant le palais de justice de
versailles le 7 décembre prochain il
comparaît pour des faits de détournement
de fonds publics et réalisations et de
faux documents commis alors qu'il était
en fonction entre 2015 et 2018 des infra
seraient des infractions révélées en
juillet 2019 après la plainte d'une
femme son ancienne maîtresse lui
laissant miroiter qui allie la qu'il
allait se marier avec elle serge morvan
a produit de faux banc de mariage alors
qu'il était encore avec son épouse de
l'époque un autre faux documents et est
également fabriquée en se servant ce
journal officiel en outre le préfet a
détourné plus de 10000 euros de deniers
publics pour financer son idylle
restaurant séjour ou encore plein
d'essence en contrepartie ils paient est
des dépenses de l'état avec ses deniers
personnels est défait que serge morvan a
déjà reconnu et en bref ce jeudi en fin
de matinée les pompiers ont été appelés
rue nationale à mantes la jolie pour une
alerte au monoxyde de carbone une
parfumerie du groupe marionnaud et des
habitations alentour ont dû être
évacuées les secouristes ont installé un
poste médical chez l'opticien voisin
trois personnes ont tout de même étaient
transportés et hospitalisés mais leurs
vies ne sont pas en danger actuellement
et d'après les premières investigations
qui nous remontent à 18h24 actuellement
sur place c'est un gaz nocif 1 qui
proviendraient en fait une voiture de
collection qui était stationnée au sous
sol du bâtiment
cette voiture de collection avait été à
laisser le moteur de cette voiture de
collection tournai le propriétaire
l'avait laissé tourner et le monoxyde de
carbone s'est infiltrée ensuite par les
conduits de ventilation pour intoxiquer
le magasin nous précise d'ailleurs que
le propriétaire pourrait être poursuivi
par la justice et du sport à présent
avec la présentation du dakar 2021 ce
mercredi un livre noir participera une
nouvelle fois à ce rallye raid jean
pierre garçon originaire de montesson
sera le copilote de christian lavieille
chez toyota ce sera sa 22e participation
la première remontant maintenant à
l'édition 1997 l'année dernière livrée
noah avait terminé l'épreuve au 28e rang
il espère faire aussi bien lors de cette
43e édition qui sera organisée du 3 au
15 janvier dans les dunes d'arabie
saoudite
on l'écoutait interrogé par michael et
demi d'euros changer l'équipe un peu
plus de motivation avec une belle
voiture donc une belle voiture une bonne
voiture
donc c'est très bien
et avant de se quitter un joyeux
anniversaire à robert marchand qui fête
ses 109 ans rien que ça ce jeudi le
cycliste est détient de nombreux records
dans sa catégorie d'âge notamment celui
du record du monde de l'heure sur piste
battu en 2017 c'était au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
un record battu en parcourant 22 km et
547 m le tout en une heure bravo à lui
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité dans un instant vous
retrouvez un nouveau numéro de
l'émission à 6 on rentre et qui vous
occupe pendant cette période de
confinement des belles soirées sur tv 78
[Musique]